maniobra aérea para detener a un
opositor 170 pasajeros de 12
nacionalidades iban a bordo del vuelo
49 78 destino a vilna lituania desde
atenas grecia a punto de llegar a su
destino el avión recibió un aviso de las
autoridades de belarús de una amenaza de
bomba en la aeronave por lo que el
trayecto fue desviado hacia la capital
bielorrusa minsk escoltada por un caza
por orden del presidente alexander
lukashenko entre los pasajeros se
encontraba el periodista román
protosevich de 26 años fundador de dos
canales de telegrama muy seguidos
durante las protestas pro-democracia
bielorrusas de 2020 el periodista
regresaba a su casa en lituania donde
está exiliado desde 2019 bajo asilo
político en su país belarrús está
acusado de organización de disturbios
cargos que pueden conllevar hasta 15
años de prisión en noviembre de 2020 la
calle ve bielorrusa los servicios
secretos del país le incluyeron en la
lista de personas involucradas en
actividades terroristas según los
testigos aportados por
pasajeros del avión el joven periodista
se dio cuenta enseguida del objetivo
real de la maniobra de desvío tan solo
aterrizar el reportero fue detenido por
las autoridades bielorrusas plan web voz
and out cuando anunciaron que íbamos a
aterrizar en minsk román podrá ser yx se
levantó y abrió los compartimientos del
equipaje y empezó a dar su computador su
iphone y otras cosas a su novia strange
y distintas autoridades internacionales
han condenado la acción del mandatario
bielorruso señalado por los altos
niveles de represión a la oposición
política este es un serio y peligroso
incidente que requiere investigación
internacional
belarús debe asegurar el retorno seguro
de todo el personal y pasajeros del
avión tras siete horas de espera en
belarús los pasajeros retomaron el viaje
hacia lituania dejando atrás al
periodista román portase beach y a su
pareja